le transforme et commercialise des
produits pays en grandes surfaces à la
réunion mais aussi en métropole
j'écris l'entreprise pour plusieurs
raisons donc que la première raison
c'était on a une petite fille et ma
compagne du tout pareil comme une
solution pas la garde et donc j'ai dû
démissionner de mon ancien poste jusqu'à
les traditions de 7,4 pouvoir subvenir à
mes besoins et passer du temps avec ma
fille la voir grandir et deuxième
motivation c'est que je travaillais
avant d'une société agroalimentaire ça
me manque et de travailler dans ce
secteur là du tout les trémas trois
boîtes incruste ateliers de production
je suis allé vendre mes produits web
je n'ai pas de piment nous avons des
sirops de la confiture des épices les
préparations trop maranger
piqué
on priorise réellement la production
locale on travaille sans poids santé
j'ai trop d'huile à sont préparés de
manière artisanale
notre produit phare aujourd'hui c'est
notre match aller nous avons avons su
garder la méthode de fabrication c'est
près de mes grands parents
son but c'est de céder continuer ce que
nos gramounes ont fait dans le temps pas
perdre
la richesse de la réunion quoi de nos
valeurs c'est ma fierté aujourd'hui pour
que je vois qu'il a vraiment envie j'ai
envie de l'aider moi aussi ça me motive
ça me pousse à l'aider n'a commencé
comme ça avec un un petit kilo de masse
aller c'est ce qui fait la force de
tradition dans 7 cas tradition parce
qu'on veut garder les méthodes
ancestrales traditionnelle et 9 7 4 pour
donner ce côté jeunes sur la façon de
les ventes l'intention de les
commercialiser
donc j'ai créé la structure en tant
qu'auto-entrepreneur ça s'est bien
développé mais passé en eurl jean paul
maso mais sa hargne et l'envié j'ai
trois salariés quand j'ai quitté
l'entreprise travaille avant donc j'ai
pu bénéficier de deux années de
l'assedic j'ai pu faire un petit prêt
avec l'adieu silva a permis de lancer
une nouvelle gamme de produits notre
site internet et puis d'acheter nos
cartons pour l'exportation
et puis nous avons eu la chance d'avoir
le soutien du président de la chambre
d'agriculture qui nous ont mis en
relation des producteurs en direct comme
il fallait investir dans du matériel et
cetera ici fallait me sentir un salaire
ça n'était pas possible
j'en ai jamais pu créer cette entreprise
a parce que j'ai une famille à nourrir
j'ai envie de garder cet aspect
entreprise familiale
mais ouvrir quand même à des jeunes et
aussi donner une seconde chance aux
personnes âgées qui souhaitent reprendre
une activité
l'amélioration que je souhaiterais
apporter à mon entreprise déjà cédé des
locaux un peu plus adapté aujourd'hui
nous avons l'atelier de production mais
pas encore de bureau donc éventuellement
d'avoir un petit bureau c'est surtout
d'investir dans matériel grande notre
cadre de travail un peu plus agréable